hello and welcome to the evan carmichael
show i believe an entrepreneur this show
is for you it's about helping you get
your business to where you want to be
and building something that you can be
proud of i'm a little stressed out this
week because tomorrow i am off to
malaysia i'm doing a few keynote
presentations and i'm meeting with the
prime minister to help them plan their
national social media campaign and we
had monday off so it's all crammed down
into a three-day week which is crazy but
i love you guys i have to be here for
you on the radio show so i'm excited to
be here with you this morning
on the show today
how do you find your passion
how to stand out in a competitive market
what do i think about the tv show shark
tank
and how do you get your logo design so
let's kick it off how do you find your
passion this is really important okay
this is so important because if you want
to have success as an entrepreneur
then you need to start a business around
something that you're passionate about
too many entrepreneurs go into business
just trying to make money if that's your
goal it's never going to work it's never
going to work look at the list of of the
richest entrepreneurs in the world look
at how they got started and money was
never their number one goal
money was never their number one goal
yet here they are the richest people in
the world
they started the business because they
were passionate about it and that's what
you need to do with your business as
well
one of my favorite stores is uh george
lucas created lucasfilm founder of films
like star wars indiana jones
and when he first got into the film
business
he thought he'd never make any money on
it he was doing it because he just he
loved doing it he loved film everybody
said he was crazy you should go back and
get a real job and the first six years
of his business career were just a total
failure
failure after failure after failure
after failure
and he thought constantly about going
back and getting the job
doing the smart thing
listening to the people in his life the
little man in his life who don't believe
in what he's all about
i think about that would you keep going
would you go past six years
six years of not seeing any results
would you keep doing it would you keep
going
the only thing that gets you through is
that you're passionate about it you said
i have to i have to keep going i don't
care that ever makes money i have to
keep doing this because i love it i'll
find another way to make money but i
have to keep focusing on this that's
when you know you're on the right thing
you're on the right path
you have to love what you do
so how do you get started
now i have an entire zuga guide that
walks you through step by step
how to find your passion but i'll try to
condense that in a nutshell
you start by thinking about everything
you're passionate about
think about the things that you can you
can get lost in
things that you you start at nine in the
morning you look up and it's five at
night and you don't even know where the
time went
that's the kind of stuff you need to be
focusing on
and you need to find out how does that
match up with something that's going to
add value to other people's lives
something that you love
and it also helps other people if you
want to get paid you want to make a lot
of money you have to add a lot of value
to people's lives you want to make a lot
of money you got to add a lot of value
you want to make a lot of money quickly
you got to add a lot of value quickly
and when you can combine those things
something that you love to do
with something that helps people
that's the that's the magic ingredient
that's when you're gonna start making
a lot of money and see a lot of momentum
happening with your business
if you don't know what your passion is
yet
don't freak out okay don't get scared
don't get nervous
you may not know what it is yet
and that may mean you have to go and
explore
try new things don't be afraid to reach
out
and try your hand at something and don't
put so much pressure on it this has to
be the idea
you have to listen to your heart
and when you find the right opportunity
you'll know that you need to keep going
with it
believe
i want to get to the call i have terry
on the line terry where are you from and
how can i help
i am from west virginia and i just have
a general question i am looking at
opening possibly opening a restaurant
that i am definitely passionate about
i've been competing in chile
competitions for years
and
everybody tells me i have to be open to
my own restaurant and i've really been
thinking about that and
it would have i'd have like 10 craft
just really good solid
chilies and then some craft beer and
nothing too fancy but where would i go
to get a business yes chili gourmet
chili okay cool
gourmet chili and
and then have some like a
craft beer
selected craft beer uh where would i go
to get a good solid business plan
what would you recommend me but you have
a great recipe on your own and you're
trying to figure out how to make this a
restaurant
well
i do have and then i also had access to
a lot of world winners
that would be willing to share recipes
with me to
put into the restaurant
and it it would be like you could have
i have 10 staple chilies and of course
i'd rotate like two new ones every month
and then you would you could have a bowl
of chili or then you could the second
it's going to be in three parts the
second part then you can have it over
something like over some french fries or
pasta or rice or tortillas or
and then are you are you selling this
now or just these are recipes you've
created in your house and for your
friends
these are recipes that have
been
world chili championship recipes
okay
and other people are making winners
i know you want to make it yourself i
can make it well no i i make i make two
world championship chilis myself me
personally
and you've gone to awards and you've won
it at these shows
right
that's what i that's one of my hobbies
is i compete in chile competitions
throughout the world that's really cool
i'm getting hungry for some chili right
now
yeah yeah so
so i am in the chili circuit i know the
chili circuit and nowhere
and when i go to these events there are
thousands of people that line up just to
eat
chili i mean
but you know if you think about building
a list of people who are loyal to you
like people who have bought from you who
want to hear more who if you said hey
i'm open up this shop
they'll come up and line up
oh yeah
yeah that's what yeah everybody that i
know is like you need to do this i'm
being pushed into it i mean it was an
idea that i just started throwing out
this and everyone that i've mentioned it
to they're like that's fabulous because
there's nowhere to go get chili i mean
if you think of chili you think of
wendy's i mean they branded if you think
about it wendy's
branded
one single ball of chili and
that's where you go
and so do you have the money to launch
this restaurant or this is what you need
to plan for no
this is what uh my question was yes i
need a good solid business plan and i
need you know financial backing
do you know how much where would you go
um
i'm estimating probably
because i don't want anything really
really fancy starting off just something
simple
um
less than 100 000 probably maybe even
50. that's why i needed a solid business
plan that really see
if the market would hold that and
everything so you know that so right
yeah and you got to get
you got to get that number down
right you got to get that number i
haven't even done that i haven't even i
haven't even went that far you know i
haven't broke down like the ingredients
in the chili and how much i got to sell
the chili for i haven't done any of that
yet
you know what i would do if i was you
have you heard of score
no
score is a it's a it's a free resource
open to
entrepreneurs across america where
basically it's uh people with experience
are giving their time and volunteering
to help out
entrepreneurs who are trying to make a
name for themselves and get started and
launch their businesses
because what you need is somebody who is
in the restaurant business who has done
it before
and can walk you through the
step-by-step because just having a
business plan isn't going to be enough
for you
right you are great at doing the chili
and you perfected that you're the best
in the world at that
and now you need somebody to help you
build the business side of it who can
talk all the numbers right
get everything going give you so you
need a business partner or you need the
mentor
there's lots of place to go for business
plan but the hard part is actually
implementing it because i don't want you
to go out and take out a loan for a
hundred thousand dollars and end up
failing and it's not going to be because
your chili is not good it's because
you don't know how to build a restaurant
exactly
so i would look i would look at score i
would look at score i think it's
score.org
and these are
successful a lot of time retired
entrepreneurs they want to give back
they want to help out
and you can find someone who's had
experience in the restaurant business
maybe not in chile like you have to
bring the chili expertise but they're
the restaurant experts who can help give
you advice and guide you towards success
in building this thing up right and i
would be willing to even take on um a
partner that that knew that side of the
business
you know because that's
part of the business that i don't know
yeah and there may be someone i'll
definitely take that heavy world
who if you put it out to your network
and say this is what i'm looking for
they may come to you as well say oh i
love her chili i've tried it it's the
best i'd love to partner up with her
there may be somebody already in the
chili world who loves that
but also look at score
to find those advisors or
thank you so much
no problem and for everybody listening
in
if you really want to do something you
don't have the skills and expertise it
doesn't mean you have to go and learn
everything yourself right terry's the
best of making chili in the world
so she partners up with somebody who
understands the business side and help
her open that restaurant and get her
name up there to have a lot more success
welcome back to the evan carmichael show
i believe in entrepreneurs i want to see
you have massive success with your
company
and part of that is going to be standing
out in a competitive field no matter
what product or service you sell you're
up against a lot of competition and i
get asked often how do i stand out how
do i win business away from my
competitors
my answer
is to combine your passions
to do things that are uniquely you that
nobody else can duplicate
too many times in business you're just
picking one thing that you're good at
and that's what you run with where the
bigger success will be by combining
different things that you love into one
and that's how you sign up from
everybody else let me give you an
example a buddy of mine is an investment
advisor financial advisor okay
super competitive field how do you stand
out as a financial advisor there's tons
of them and everybody sells the same
product you're all selling the same
stuff so name is steve
we went through this and
and steve's passion
in life besides investment advice is
hockey
hockey you know he's the guy who watches
sportscenter replays can see the same
goal 40 times
and just loves watching his wife looks
at him and says steve you're crazy how
can you watch the same thing so many
times i don't know i love it he loves
hockey
so how do you combine
investment advice with hockey
these are the two biggest passions in
his life
and by combining those two things that's
what's going to make him different from
every other single investment advisor
out there
so how did he do it
steve now is the go-to guy for
investment advice for nhl hockey players
he combined his love of investment
advice with hockey and going after high
net worth individuals right investment
advisors they all want to go after the
guys with the big bucks they don't want
to deal with the people who have 100
bucks a month to contribute they want
the guys to have millions of dollars
but everybody's going after them
and he can't just go in and say hey i'm
steve
i love investment advice here's why i'm
great because that's the same thing as
everybody else
he competes because he loves hockey so
much it's his deep passion so now when
he's going out and pitching people and
talking to them he can talk about hockey
too and they see the passion
and now he's the go-to guy
so when nhl players are sitting there
saying
who we're going to go to for investment
advice
steve is the man
he has a lot more fun
he's making a lot more money
he's a lot more successful and the turn
only happened when he started combining
his passions so think about in your
business
how you can combine your passions
what is it that you sell what is it that
you do hopefully you're passionate about
that
as a first starting point but what else
is there in your life that you love
doing how can you incorporate that into
your business because when you figure
that out
you're going to have a lot more success
and have a lot more fun and it's a lot
harder
for any competitor to come in and scoop
your clients
because they can't be you
you are the differentiating factor and
what you love to do so stop trying to be
like everybody else
and be you
believe
i want to get to the call i have heath
on the line keith where are you from and
how can i help
hi evan i'm out of uh
northern california in elk grove
california
northern california all right what do
you do
and we sell into the irrigation and
agriculture market okay so so we're not
in construction but we're actually uh
a rep agency that we sell for different
manufacturers uh that don't have their
own sales agencies in the marketplace
okay so your outsourced sales correct
correct
and we've been running into a problem
recently developed uh
a new product actually i developed a new
product and
it it feels a
it feel the need there's a it fixes some
of the inherent problems of its
competitors in the marketplace
it's also less expensive
and it's been extremely well received by
our contractor and end users
however
our main channel sales is through
wholesale distribution
and
we cannot seem to break into
the wholesale even with the contractor
pull
so
that's kind of my question to you is how
do you go about
selling a product that has a resistance
at the actual true or first
buyer i guess would be the question
why is there a resistance uh the main
thing that comes up is that there's
we already have
too many of this product
so it gets
it gets instantly looked at as it's the
same as the other even though they're
you know we've explained over and over
again the differences and they do
understand it it's that
it's that main reason right there we
already have several of these is what
you're told
okay
my biggest thing when you're launching a
new product is you have to reduce the
fear
so
their words are going to buy a whole
bunch of inventory that just sits on
their shelves or i guess they don't have
shelves but you know what i'm talking
about so yes how can you make it so that
you reduce the risk so that they buy one
or a small quantity and then you help
them promote it
so they can see the difference and you
can see the people want it because all
you need is one store
you know one wholesaler to say
hey this really worked
then you could take everybody else you
have your proof of concept right
nobody's taking this on yet and is
willing to do it nobody's taking that
face with you
correct so how can you reduce the risk
so that it's such a low quantity and
you're going to help them promote it you
work on one location
one company make it super easy for them
to say yes
and build your proof of concept with
them
the the first thing that would come to
mind would be some type of a guaranteed
buyback
for the distributor if they don't sell
it
and then would just be
us going out with their sales people and
promoting it
very heavily
yeah um which we have done in the past
but it's very time consuming but
obviously if we want to sell it this is
probably how we're going to have to do
it
and this is not necessarily going to be
your long-term strategy having that
guaranteed buyback is not necessarily
something you want to lock yourself into
long-term but your goal here is to get
one company having success selling your
product
and reordering
and you could take that as a
case model to go to the everybody else
and say well that's what these guys said
too and look what happened i like the
case model idea because that's that's
exactly what we'd have to use to push to
the next one or the next one
yeah and you guys are expert sales
people right this is what you do as your
business you might be able to help train
their guys and make their guys better at
selling everything not just your product
but everything that they they have on
their shelf
and i like the i like using a single one
and starting it that way instead of how
we've been doing it is blanketing and
trying to get everybody to bring one in
but look at one case study and go from
there
okay good
all right thank you
all right take care hey for everybody
in and you're trying to launch a new
product you're trying to get awareness
out there
don't try to hit everybody all at once
to show that it works with one person
one company get one sale and make it
work for them have them send global
reviews out for you
and they'll help you do so much work to
get everybody else on board
hello and welcome back to the evan
carmichael show i believe in
entrepreneurs i want to see you have a
lot of success with your company
and part of that is getting access to
resources and educating yourself and
learning the things that you don't know
and i got asked recently
uh by one of my youtube viewers arturo
who wrote in to say evan what do you
think about the tv show shark tank
and he was a little upset with shark
tank because they
do a lot of flash deals and he feels
like sometimes they pressure people to
make a deal on the spot
and he wasn't sure if that was a good
thing for entrepreneurs or not so let me
let me back out a little bit on this
before i dive deep
with sharks tank you gotta remember this
is made for tv right these deals are not
happening in the three minutes that you
see it on tv they might be in it for a
half an hour an hour two hours
negotiating something okay those deals
do take time
also keep in mind that just because you
get
a handshake deal that doesn't mean
anything the real deal happens later and
a lot of deals actually fall apart
afterwards in what they call due
diligence so you're both doing your
research on each other a lot of the
deals that they shake on don't actually
end up even happening
and as entrepreneurs you know that
you're getting into the shark tank right
you don't go on that show without
knowing what's going to happen right you
know the questions are going to ask you
you know the characters if you don't
then then you're not prepared right if
you're going to go on that show you
should watch and see what's happening
shark tank has a special place in my
heart because it's a whole series so
this this show this concept
became popular in the uk certain japan
became pop in the uk called dragon's den
and i helped bring it to canada
where it became dragon's den and then
mark burnett brought it to
the united states and named it shark
tank and he brought the two best
canadians with him from dragon's den
kevin o'leary and robert herjavec
to be on shark tank so mr wonderful
started up in uh in canada on giant exam
he's still on it
me i love the show
i've seen i think every episode i love
the show
and i don't think that there's enough
quality programming for entrepreneurs
especially on tv
before shark tank what was there
nothing
right and look at how popular that show
is look at how many people tune in and
watch there is an entire nation of
people who want to be entrepreneurs who
want to launch their businesses who are
looking for inspiration education advice
on what to do
and that's why shark tank is popular so
i think
a responsibility that you have
as an entrepreneur is to support the
people who are on the same mission as
you so whatever your whatever you stand
for whatever movement you're trying to
build whatever you think is really
important in your life things that
people need to know about
i believe that it's your
duty
to share those things and support the
people who are trying to do great things
so i love shark tank
i'll tweet out about it i'll share the
episodes things that i like about it
there's another show called the prophet
which is on cnbc it's uh started by
marcus lemonis to just start in their
second season
and i love the show too here's a guy who
goes in he's investing his own money
into companies who are struggling and he
helps turn them around
that's the point of the show
and i don't know how well the show is
doing right now i hope it's doing well
but i i tweeted out
to mark and said marcus what you're
doing is important keep going
and i share episodes of the show and i
share some of the things that he talks
about because he's on the same mission
as me
he's trying to help entrepreneurs he
just he's attacking from a different
angle
so i think it's your duty responsibility
to reach out to people
who are trying to do the same thing as
you
and support them because there's gonna
be days where they
doubt themselves or they feel like
quitting
and having somebody say
you inspire me
you help me keep going thank you so much
for what you're doing that could be the
difference between them continuing on
and stopping
the best part of my day is when i wake
up in the morning and go to my computer
and look at my youtube comments because
people leaving such great comments about
how i've helped them
and that keeps me going
so i love shark tank i love the profit i
love everything that they they stand for
and helping entrepreneurs and if there's
something that you believe in you see
some good being done in the world
support them they can be financially it
could be as simple as a tweet just
support them and let them know that what
they're doing is important
believe i have helen on the line helen
my producer says that you're very cheery
so i'm excited for this call helen where
are you from and how can i help
i'm an american citizen from france
and i'm so pleased with the program
on the video
this morning how are you evan i'm very
good i i i'm excited to have you here on
the line what what's your business thank
you well i own a kids act oc in orange
county california
in business for 13 years i also have a
book out called eternal published by amy
osmond on social media books she's
murray and donnie osmond's niece
and actually have a question about my
book
okay
how can i increase
the sales of my book eternal
and
i also secure a movie deal for my
trilogy it's a young adult trilogy on a
tv series or a network uh pertaining to
a tv series or get a movie deal or a tv
series on a network like the cw for
instance hello cw people call me
uh
the book has been what's the message
that you get out with the book what do i
learn from the book what's the one thing
that i'm gonna like in this book it's
it's a young adult paranormal romance
and it's about the fact that
love
never dies and so these two people
throughout different lifetimes
come back together and that's also the
concept for the tv series or the movie
okay so what you need to do
is build a community
okay
if you want to get
this book taken off if you want to get a
tv deal movie rights all of that stuff
you need to have momentum you need to
have a community of people to show that
hey this is important
we love this book and we love
what helen stands for i guess elaine is
it alan
oh you're so good it's it's thailand but
elaine in france yes who california if
your concept is love never dies
yes then you want to
build up a network so you create a
facebook page you create a twitter
account and you're not sharing stuff
just about the book because that gets
too promotional people don't want to
hear just about the book but you're
sharing things that relate to love never
dies
so it could be from a different movie it
could be famous quotes that inspire you
that relate to love and it never never
dine
you want to support the people who are
also talking about this just like i
talked in this segment about marcus
lemon as the prophet you want to reach
out to other people who have the same
belief
actually i have a huge uh follow-up on
twitter and facebook
i'm at hg nadal on twitter
and i don't know if i'm supposed to do
this but and it's eternal book on
facebook so
people are welcome to follow and like
oh my gosh was i supposed to say all
this
it's okay the thing is here
it has to be bigger
right okay what you're doing has to be
bigger so it's great that you already
have a fan base and i'm assuming the
book is really good but it has to be
bigger
so when you're talking about
the book it's not just talking about the
book and it's not just promoting your
twitter account or your facebook account
it's talking about
this concept
of love never dies i make it important
you want people
who are listening to this radio show who
are listening
to every other interview that you do who
are watching your twitter account
if you're just promoting your book
people are going to tune out because
it's not interesting
but if you're talking about
love never dies
and sharing inspirational ideas about it
then that's going to get people
intrigued
and interested
i want to join that is wanna learn i
like
i like that i like that
i've been sending messages to because my
uh
fan base is
very young and i've been sending
messages pertaining to
uh texts when you're there you know
because i want for kids to be safe out
there but i love what you're saying
so if there are if there are you can
even have quotes from the book
you know whatever the main character is
you can have
him or her
giving inspirational
messages that you quote
see now you want something people are
going to share
you want a message that touches people
that makes them feel something so they
want to share it
they're not just going to share your
twitter account or the cover of your
book and say go buy this you have to
make them feel something first
right
so
you you already have like whatever
inspired you to write this book
put that stuff together and use it in
all your social media accounts and all
your promotions make me feel something
and then i'll follow you does that make
sense
absolutely this was uh
amazing this is a breakthrough um
good luck with the the promotion and
keep me posted with it okay
okay
hey for everybody listening stand for
something important
and put that message out there you want
people to share your stuff it's not
going to be by you screaming the name of
your book and social media accounts it's
going to be by you standing for
something important and making people
feel something
so that they want to come to you i
believe in entrepreneurs i want to see
you have a lot of success with your
company this year and i want your
marketing to take off and i got asked
recently by an entrepreneur how do i get
my logo designed for my website it's
important
so there's a couple ways to do it and my
favorite logo story is nike nike
has one of the most iconic logos in the
world and it was designed by a
university of oregon student that phil
knight paid less than 100 bucks
to get done so even nike was
bootstrapped in the early days and built
one of the biggest brands in the world i
have a few tools that i want to share
with you that you can write down and go
investigate that you may not have heard
of before so the first one i want you to
check out is 99designs.com this is a
great resource to use for any design
work or basically you submit your
design your idea what you need to get
done and designers from around the world
will bid on it
and they'll actually do the work and
create designs for you and you get to
pick a winner so you only pick
one design you can give them feedback on
it
and you're only paying for a winning
design so this is the biggest challenge
that i had before with craft design work
is you're looking at somebody's past
portfolio but you don't know if they're
going to be
helping you for what you want to do
we're here you're only paying for final
design
another great resource to check out is
odesk.com i'm a huge fan of odesk and
it's basically people from around the
world who are skilled at what they do
who work remotely and you can put in a
job request and say hey i need somebody
to design my logo here's what i'm
looking for and again people will submit
their resumes and their password and you
can pick someone if you want somebody
longer term part of your team you need a
lot of work done oh that's a good route
to go if you want
someone just to create kind of one-off
designs for you then nine-nine designs
is the best way to go and you can also
look local hey there's a lot of local
talent wherever you are
nike's logo was designed by a local
university of oregon student that's how
they got started
so look to your local community look to
your local
network to see if there's somebody who
can help you out but you need to have a
logo that stands for something that
makes you feel good that that you can
you know proudly put on t-shirts and
business cards and websites and show up
to the world to help your marketing grow
i want to get to the call to have time
for one last caller i have
tony on the line tony my producer says
you sound like a manly man
oh yeah where are you from tony um from
russell rock arkansas arkansas all right
what's your business how can i help
uh actually uh um i have a taxicab
service i designed it um in 2005
and you know ever since then businesses
are going pretty good you know
okay what kind of service was it a taxi
cab service taxicab
yes sir okay great so how can i help
well actually um
basically you know i'm just i just want
to what you what you want to jump and
tell you how uh everything about my
business or how you what i'm gonna tell
you well tell me what your biggest we
don't have a whole ton of time tell me
what the biggest problem is you're
facing that what do you need help with
i'm doing pretty good i don't need help
i just thought i thought maybe i was
going to tell my story
okay
sorry let's hear it
okay basically i started this company in
2005 and um eric says then i've been
making over ten thousand dollars a week
and
all it is
is promotion you know whenever you
promote something you know
it's basically on autopilot and um all i
did is you know
created some flyers
i put them all all the hotels and bars
and restaurants
and you know whenever people need a ride
they just
they just called me and um i started to
come outside a ride to work program
when you know basically when people
you know need to ride that there and
back or whatever i just i charged them
um i created this car called uh weekly
unlimited prepaid card
and that's when they paid like maybe
like a hundred dollars for the for the
whole week weekly card
and um you know the way they can it's
affordable and
you know
2005 2005 and how many people are on
your team now i have over 20 some people
right now and basically uh i charge them
a percentage of 10
and um say if they make
400 bucks or so i get i get 10 percent
out of that it's like what 40 bucks
and um
what i mean i want to start this
business
because i had a hard time finding a job
like
again i got tired of you know they kept
telling me that they're not hiring at
the moment and stuff like that so i say
hey i need to do something i need to
start my own business and this is the
end you can empower yourself
yes i empowered myself this is the end i
had a job in 10 years
why taxi cabs i mean because it's like
basically it's like you know i wanted my
freedom
to spend time with my family and
you know basically i just want to be my
own boss and
and you know just call the shots or
whatever and it's basically like free
money you don't have to pay anything you
just basically just pass off flyers
business cards and get on you know the
internet and the phone book and it just
works itself okay so tony if there's
somebody out there there's somebody
listening right now who's struggling to
get a job who can't you know they've
been turned down everywhere they're
going and they're kind of giving up they
don't know what to do what advice would
you give them
i would have to say you know they have
to think of something that that they're
good at
and whatever they're good at all it
takes is
basically just getting out there and
promoting it you know if you have to
promote in the phone book or the
internet
like why peop you know get on yp.com or
google
and it's a site called um
freebusinesslisteners.com
where you can create your own websites
and your own search engine optimizations
that way with people searching for you
on google you know you'll pop up and
they're calling you
and you just create some business card i
mean business cards and flyers and
promote every day if you promote every
day
you'll be successful
for the rest of your life right
well thank you tony for joining us and
for sharing your story
all right no problem take care
hey for everybody listening you know
usually people call in and ask me with
uh they have a question but that was
cool just to hear the story and what
he's up to if you're in the same
situation that tony was back in 05
where
you're trying to get a job and you can't
find anything and people just turning
you down and you know it's on you this
is your responsibility you can empower
yourself just like tony did
and start your own business find
something that you're passionate about
find something that excites you find
something that you can now you know
start to feel like you're doing
something valuable again you have some
good self-worth built back in get some
confidence back in again
empower yourself don't wait for the job
to come don't wait for the government to
support you this is on you to be
successful
make your life successful the calvary
isn't coming
i want to thank everybody for listening
today it's been a lot of fun i'm off to
malaysia tomorrow night i want to
especially thank my producers lauren and
fernanda you guys rocked it again i'm
going to be on again in two weeks
i hope you call in
i want to talk to you i'm excited to
hear about your business and your
progress and until then keep believing